adapting to sudden and unexpected
changes is a core tenet of human
survival however abruptly finding
yourself trapped in an apparently
infinite extra dimensional pocket
dimension in the form of a never-ending
Ikea while that can take a brief
adjustment period to get used to Callan
hadn't even noticed for the first few
moments wandering through the aisles
aimlessly passing Isles of hemnids and
trisils all the assembled display pieces
of affordable flat pack Furniture it
would have been more exciting shopping
for all the accoutrements for his brand
new apartment if Callan wasn't being
perpetually reminded that he was moving
in there on his own it took him almost
20 minutes of walking through the row of
Ikea products for him to realize
something felt off he had hardly seen
anybody else around in fact the more he
thought about it there hadn't even been
any employees in their garish yellow
Polo shirts and blue pants at the front
of the store squinting off in the
distance Callan couldn't even see the
far wall of the store sure he knew I
Outlets were big inside somewhere
between a supermarket and an industrial
warehouse but this place seemed to go on
forever figuring that he had unknowingly
stumbled out of the store proper and
into a large storage area Callan turned
around and started to try to retrace his
steps back to the entrance it was after
another 20 minutes of taking this
approach that things went from feeling
off to being overtly unsettling by the
time that over an hour had passed Kellen
was starting to panic racing through the
seemingly unending store the rubber
soles of his sneakers squeaking against
the epoxy resin floor as he yelled
loudly for somebody anybody that might
hear him before long the latest victim
to find themselves lost inside
scp-3008 was hitting the first
existential hurdle that came with being
trapped in the infinite Ikea Kellen sat
on a display couch a two-seated solder
hem with a shade Lounge in case anyone
was wondering he was curled up into a
ball knees tucked under his chin as he
gently started rocking himself back and
forth in a feudal attempt to comfort
himself it hadn't yet quite sunk in just
how trapped he was the thought that he
might starve to death amongst the
endless talk of Soros and fjartigs the
stores now closed please exit the
building the sudden sound of a voice
startled Callan snapping him out of his
dread-filled Daydream enough to realize
the store now seemed darker the lights
had been gradually dimming the longer he
had stayed creating an artificial night
within scp-3008 normally the sign of
another person after being isolated
would come as a relief but whoever had
spoken was nowhere to be seen a slow
shuffling moved around the sofa Callum
was sitting on until he finally called
out into the dark hello is anyone there
there was a pause the movement stopped
for an agonizingly quiet moment the
store is now closed please exit the
building the voice repeated as the
Unseen speaker stepped Out of the
Shadows even in the low light the
creature was horrifying everything about
it was just wrong for a split second
Callum thought it might be an Ikea
employee was wearing the uniform after
all but the bodily proportions were all
off arms hanging nearly all the way down
to the floor hands and fingers enlarged
and elongated as for its face it didn't
have one the ordinary features were all
missing and now it was running right for
him Callan leaped over the back of the
sotterheim and ran his first instinct
was to get away and hide checking over
his shoulder he got inside of the
faceless creature dashing right past the
couch with enough Force to knock it over
in his startled State looking out of the
corner of his eye at the encroaching
staff member Callan tripped over his
feet and tumbled back down to the hard
floor the creature loomed over him as he
tried to crawl towards a nearby aisle
looking up at it the staff member was
reaching for him its big
disproportionate hand outstretched
trying to grab at Kalan see lay there
helplessly suddenly something struck the
faceless creature someone barely visible
in the dim lights of the store had
leaped down from the shells of the aisle
and swung a makeshift weapon at the
staff member as it connected the
creature reeled stumbling over itself
long enough for the mystery assailant to
take another swipe at it their weapon
comprised what looked like part of a
curtain rail with a pair of kitchen
knives at one end impaled the staff
member ripping through its bright yellow
Ikea Polo and out on the other side
striding over to where Callum was still
laying on the floor all struck by the
display he just witnessed the figure
pulled back the hood of a rudimentary
cloak they were wearing fashioned by
hand out of an Aina curtain fabric
revealing herself with a Stern serious
look on her face the woman reached a
handout to Callan offering to help him
up rather than whatever that faceless
creature had wanted with him it's okay
I'm not gonna hurt you she stated as she
pulled him back to his feet this is
probably all pretty confusing for you
right still too stunned to speak Callan
just nodded yeah it was for me too the
woman replied we don't have long until
more staff show up so you need to come
with me and don't ask questions okay
seeing him not again she took Helen's
head and let him through the dark
recesses of the infinite Ikea stealthily
the pair of them snuck through the
aisles keeping low and ducking down out
of sight whenever more of the staff
lumbered into their path until they had
wandered elsewhere clearing the way for
them to proceed kellen's new guide
seemed to instinctively know her way
around the layout of the sprawling Maze
of flat pack Swedish Furniture quietly
urging him to stay close offering him a
hand up when they climbed up shelving
units until finally they arrived at
their destination a warm glow emanated
from somewhere beyond a tall makeshift
barrier sofas and cabinets were stacked
on top of each other forming an
intricate wall around an area of
scp-3008 and right in the middle of this
rudimentary barricade was a large
two-door Pax fardle wardrobe it's back
missing doors inwards facing towards the
inner side of the blockade the guide
stepped into the incomplete wardrobe and
gave a specifically timed knock three
beats with the third following the first
two after a short pause from the other
side it sounded like something was being
hurriedly removed from the wardrobe's
handles before the doors opened up to
allow her and Callan entry beyond the
outer wall this part of the infinite
Ikea looked to have been converted into
a small town with a sign hanging above
that red decoration population 58 there
were even more people within most in
handmade clothing crafted out of scraps
of fabric along with the remnants of old
clothes from the outside world they'd
been cut off from some looked like they
were standing on guard carrying weapons
similar to the guide's weapon others
were sitting around together talking
casually under the light of the solafeta
floor lamps okay the guide's Sigh
turning back to cala we're safe now that
we're inside the wall so you can talk
again
ah thank you he replied awkwardly for
saving me I mean don't mention it she
smiled for the first time since they had
met I'm sure you've got a lot of
questions so ask away I'll do my best to
answer as many as I can where am cone's
voice trailed off thinking of a question
he wanted to know the answer to even
more than where he was or what was up
with this place who are you the girl
smiled and offered him an outstretched
hand my name's Kia over the coming
months and with a lot of direction from
his new friend Kellen slowly started to
adjusting to living inside
scp-3008 the lifestyle was completely
different from what he was used to
before instead of renting or buying a
house or apartment the survivors had
established their own little settlements
using the copious amounts of Ikea
furniture around to construct homes for
themselves without access to money or
any need for it nobody was self-serving
either everyone chipped in and helped
each other out agreed to take on tasks
that would benefit their fellow
survivors there was a strong sense of
community inside all anyone had in the
infinite Ikea was each other they were
all in the same situation and surviving
it was made easier by cooperating Kia
took responsibility for showing Kellen
around teaching him all about life
inside
scp-3008 when he asked her why she was
so adamant about keeping an eye on him
she replied by telling him that when she
arrived she'd been scared and alone even
when the town of decoration had taken
her in Kia still needed to learn all the
basics on her own she admitted that she
wished somebody was there to teach her
and endeavored to do exactly that for
Callum she started by telling him what
the best time to head to the food court
was every day all the food and scp-3008
would somehow reappear meaning that
everyone could easily have their fill
and survive without having to hunt or
kill each other in order to eat Kia's
next lesson involved teaching Callum how
to use Ikea's stationery to leave subtle
but recognizable symbols around the
store so that if he was ever lost he
could find his way back to decoration
safely while avoiding the staff that's
the thing about living here she said
when we first arrived we all think we've
got nothing but this place has food
shelter tools everything we need we just
have to learn to use what it gives us as
time went on Callum found himself paired
up with Kia for patrols during the
daytime staff would wander aimlessly
around the store far more docile than
they were at night to make sure that
they were ready in the event of an
attack by the faceless creatures the
survivors mapped out the staff's
movements reporting back to their
settlements in case a large group of
them were wandering too close the more
they went out together the more Kellen
found himself eagerly looking forward to
being in Kia's company maybe it was just
because she was the first person he'd
met inside the infinite Ikea perhaps
because she had saved his life but there
was something about her that made him
feel a little less sad about being
trapped here a feeling that would soon
be cruelly ripped away it happened
during an otherwise normal Patrol Kia
and Callan were checking the aisles
keeping an eye on the staff and tallying
everyone they saw the lights were
starting to dim indicating that it would
soon be night again and the pair of them
agreed it was time to start heading back
to decoration that was until a sudden
screeching caught their attention what
the hell was that Cowan whispered no
idea Kia replied could be someone else
just arrived she gave a hand signal that
instructed Kellen to split up the pair
of them moved through parallel aisles
towards the source of the noise it
sounded like Stone scraping against the
floor the weight of concrete causing
whatever was being moved to generate a
grading eardrum piercing racket as he
moved silently through the now familiar
space of scp-3008 Kellen racked his
brain about what could be making a noise
like that there was nothing that heavy
or Made of Stone within Ikea at least
not that he had encountered even Kia had
looked surprised when first detecting
that sound she'd been in here for so
much longer so it was telling when even
she had no clue what had made it
suddenly the noise stopped quickly as it
had started followed by the call of a
familiar voice Callan come look at this
Kia called what is it he shouted back
trying to keep his voice low but audible
aware that staff might be nearby I don't
know some kind of statue I've never seen
anything like this in here before he was
cut off mid-sentence a quick loud scrape
of concrete against the resin floor
followed by a blood curdling scream eyes
widening and horror worried for her
safety Kellen sprinted further down the
aisle frantically calling Kia's name as
he reached the nearest Corner the screen
stopped her cries didn't fade lowering
gradually then petering off instead her
voice just cut out abruptly with a
sickening muffled crack like the sound
of bone breaking beneath the skin
panting Kellen whipped around the corner
that's when he saw her lying on the
floor totally unnervingly still her head
was tilted at an natural angle the bones
of her neck misaligned as blood dripped
from her nose Kia's body was lying at
the feet of something Callan had never
seen since he arrived at the infinite
Ikea it was some kind of sculpture
constructed out of concrete over a metal
rebar skeleton with a crude attempt to
add spray paint over its outer surface
he had no idea that this statue was
often referred to as
SCP-173 Otherwise Known simply as the
sculpture but then Callan was more
focused on how distraunt he felt that
seeing Kia dead on the floor he had
never worked up enough courage to tell
her always worry that it would make
things weird between them and now he'd
never get the chance again would never
get to see her smile as he took on the
lessons that she taught him about
surviving in scp-3008 feeling his eyes
while up Kellen blinked away tears
suddenly the sculpture shot forward in
the split second that his eyes were
closed Kellen staggered away and shock
and stumbled over landing on his back on
the floor as he went to get up scp-3008
was inches away from him having moved
yet again of its own accord carefully
Kellen stood up making sure to keep
looking straight at the Sinister statue
it was getting clear what this thing was
doing that I couldn't move while being
observed sure enough as he started to
cautiously back away one step at a time
SCP-173 stayed still frozen in place
reaching the corner his eyes stinging
desperate to Blink Callan took a deep
breath fixing his Gaze on the sculpture
for one moment longer until turning and
sprinting as fast as his legs would
allow Callum had a few short moments to
Blink sending his tears streaming down
his face behind him he could hear the
same oncoming sound of concrete scraping
heavily against the floor as the
sculpture gave Chase Callan rushed down
the aisles grabbing stacks of flat packs
off the store shelves and pulling them
onto the floor leaving piles upon piles
of mess behind him in a desperate
attempt to slow the oncoming statue down
why hadn't it killed him already perhaps
it was just playing with its food he
thought about trying to get back to
decoration wondering if maybe any of the
other surviving settlers had encountered
SCP-173 before but as he ran Callan
caught sight of some of the symbols he
and Kia had left around the store to
help them find their way around one of
them denoted that there were hiding
spots nearby and spurred him on to
change course in that direction he
couldn't lead the sculpture back to town
not if it could slaughter them all in
the blink of an eye finding a cramped
cupboard Callum climbed inside and shut
the door behind him with his knees
tucked under his chin he couldn't help
but remember the time he had arrived in
the infinite Ikea he had done almost the
exact same thing when he first
encountered a staff member he'd run and
his first instinct had been just to run
away and hide that was something about
Kia he had always wished he could be she
was Fearless easily standing up to that
staff creature that would have killed
Callan if she hadn't intervened trapped
inside a cupboard the deafening noise of
scraping concrete outside as the
sculptures searched for him Callan felt
like he'd let her down it seemed that
despite Kia's best efforts to teach him
he was still scared as he sat in the
dark praying the sculpture wouldn't find
him he apologized under his breath to
her Callum started replaying every
moment he and Kia had spent together
partly to keep her alive in his memory
but also so that he could at least think
of something good before
SCP-173 found him and broke his neck the
same way every lesson about life in
scp-3008 every one of Kia's skills she
had painstakingly passed on were still
all there including the best piece of
advice she'd ever given we have to learn
to use what this place gives us her
words echoed in his head as Callum
finally realized that she hadn't just
been talking about taking food from the
food court or using flat packs to build
shelters and settlements she'd shown him
how to navigate how to evade the staff
and at everything in the infinite Ikea
could have some usefulness in aiding
survival as much as it hurt knowing Kia
was gone Callan realized that she might
have already saved him a second time he
peeked out of the cupboard door the
bathroom section was just a quick Dash
away and SCP-173 was nowhere to be seen
a few moments later the sculpture
detected a loud sound someone knocking
things together shouting and whooping
had caught its attention unobserved the
concrete creature Zapped its way towards
the source of the commotion moving
quickly over towards the bathroom
Department of the store's endless aisles
it came to a sudden instinctive stop
sensing Eyes Were Watching it its entire
Stone body froze rigidly fixed to the
spot it was standing on it didn't matter
that the eyes watching at this time were
its own reflected back at itself in an
assortment of mirrors
SCP-173 was stuck someone had sprung a
trap for the Statue making it so that
from the moment shot over to its current
position it wouldn't be able to move it
was constantly being observed by itself
no matter what angle Its Reflection
would be within its own direct line of
sight standing atop a nearby stack of
shelves Calvin looked down at the
concrete statue trapped in a collection
of mirrors that he had assorted into a
ring hey you he called down at it hoping
it could hear him even though it was
frozen in place the store is now closed
please exit the building he struck
loudly against the metal frame of the
shelves hoping it was loud enough to be
heard sure enough the staff quickly
descended on the source of the noise the
Knight made the staff feral hostile
towards anything they sensed to be an
outside presence they instantly honed in
on SCP-173 attacking it to little veil
thanks to its Stone body eventually the
group of Staff grew a number starting to
heave the sculpture as they went to
remove it from the premises climbing
from shelf to shelf Khan followed them
the entire our way the staff had no eyes
so technically couldn't look at SCP-173
but he could even through tears he
didn't blink until the sculpture had
been removed he wanted to make sure it
was what Kia would have done now go and
check out real Ikea manager goes mad
with power in scp-3008 and scp-096
versus
SCP-173 for more videos featuring The
anomalies featured in today's Tale